lots of backpackers know about the ten
essentials these are survival items the
kind of stuff you must have with you
before heading out into the wilderness
the list may vary but it generally
includes something like a map a compass
food and water
first-aid a knife stuff like that and
then there's shelter that is what this
tarp was designed for it might not look
all that different from the blue tarps
you see down at the hardware store but
it is a French aid worker designed it
for agencies like the UN Doctors Without
Borders and the Red Cross it's four
meters wide by six meters long but they
also come in lengths of up to 60 meters
it's built to withstand some of the most
punishing conditions on earth which is
really important when you're providing
shelter to people displaced by natural
disasters persecution or political
unrest the tarp is essentially a woven
sandwich white plastic on the outsides
for heat dissipation and a super sturdy
black middle layer that absorbs plastic
destroying UV light in tests against
regular tarps in brutal coastal weather
the white one was the clear survivor
this tarp was made for relief agencies
but you can find similar tarps that are
high-quality and triple laminate like
this one online and these things aren't
just for shelter you can even turn it
into clothing or a backpack aid workers
say that the tarps versatility makes it
one of the most important pieces of gear
to have on hand in a disaster situation
so consider adding one to your
essentials list you never know when it
might come in handy
you